Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week
Agents of SHIELD finally revealed what the
Clairvoyant was, we got a good look at an
upgraded Deathlok and there was another Winter
Soldier tie in.
It was pretty easy to miss but I’ll explain
during my top moments.
Also in lieu of a bonus Marvel Movie video
I’m doing a Winter Soldier review later
this week.
Be sure to subscribe to get it if you're just
finding me for the first time.
Normally I try to do bonus Marvel videos on
Tuesdays but when really huge stuff like The
Walking Dead Finale happens I have to push
stuff around to make room.
So let’s start with Top 5 Moments and then
I’ll do my review.
Careful for spoilers from the episode if you
haven’t seen it yet.
Here we go.
Number 5 - Winter Soldier Crossover scene.
If you blinked you may have missed it, that
scene with Agent Stillwell where he said,
looks like I have a boat to catch.
It refers to the scene at the beginning of
Winter Soldier where Chris Evans has to rescue
a bunch of hostages and capture Batroc The
Leaper another notable comic book character.
I love that they do these movie integrations,
sometimes they’re hard to spot.
I think they’re more interesting when the
crossover moment is something critical to
the plot of both the story going on in the
show and whatever the plot of the movie is.
I didn’t really feel like Agent Stillwell
needed to be there other than to be Bill Paxton’s
punching bag and to drop that quick line about
the boat in Winter Soldier.
High Fives for the effort though.
Number 4 - Skye becomes a full SHIELD Agent.
One of the few positive moments in the episode.
I love the bond that Coulson has formed with
her.
He really is like her surrogate Dad now.
If it was unclear, yes they only made her
an Agent so she could access the Index, but
she’s good going forward, they’re not
going to take that away.
I also loved the follow up talk she had with
Garrett about things coming Full Circle.
It’s like Bill Paxton had foreshadowing
tattooed on his forehead.
He’s so much fun to watch though.
All of his compliments to her about inspiring
Ward while Ward was trying to inspire her
were genuine.
Despite the comic book version of his character
being really shady, he is happy to see her
become an Agent.
Number 3 - Deathlok Armors Up
The best thing about the Mike Peterson Deathlok
scenes are the interaction he has with the
tech, like watching him react to the parts
bond with his skeleton and nervous system.
I don’t care about all the explosions or
watching him run up and down stairs or jump
super high.
The armature was a really nice comic book
addition to his arsenal, but it was Skye’s
look at him beneath the skin that really stood
out.
He really is full on cyborg at this point.
They grafted all those parts on to his skeleton.
I fully expect them to redeem him at some
point, and he’ll just be a tortured hero
for the rest of the series, however long it
goes on.
Like if you ever watch Angel with David Boreanaz.
Only on Agents of SHIELD it’s Gunn who end
up being tortured by the memory of all the
people he’s killed.
What I’m saying is that J August Richards
is kind of playing the Angel role on SHIELD
now.
Which is really cool.
I wonder if Joss Whedon is going to edit any
his lines.
Everyone be sure to listen for Angel references.
Number 2 - May Is Outed As The Double Agent
We knew what she was up to after TAHITI, but
it took this long for Coulson to find out.
I liked that the explanation was much more
complicated.
She’s not just spying for HYDRA or something,
there’s this big running plot going on about
SHIELD being eaten alive from the inside.
The cancer of SHIELD is the clairvoyant and
the organization they work for.
Some of that is revealed in the Winter Soldier,
so make sure to go see it if you haven’t
already.
They actually reveal the identity of the person
behind the clairvoyant during it, which I
think kind of cheats the people who have been
watching the show.
You can let me know if you agree.
But
the rest of the season will be all about this
internal uprising in SHIELD.
The next episode is even called Turn, Turn,
Turn.
As in Agents turning on each other.
Just like Garrett was talking about with Skye.
May is just part of that.
Based on the Victoria Hand reveal at the end,
I think May was talking to her all along.
I don’t think either one of them is a double
Agent for Hydra, I just think Hand doesn’t
trust anyone and is using may to monitor Coulson.
She just doesn’t trust Couslon and Coulson
doesn trust her.
Turn Turn Turn.
and my Number 1 moment, The Clairvoyant is
a SHIELD Agent.
So this was also a confusing moment, but that
man in the chair was Brad Dourif.
The actor playing Thomas Nash.
He’s not a comic book character.
When he said Poe was the one that started
calling him the Clairvoyant he was being truthful.
The twist is that he’s not the real clairvoyant.
It’s someone or something inside SHIELD.
If you didn’t see it I did a silly video
suggesting Loki was the clairvoyant.
It was just for fun.
My real assertion was that it was a form of
AI, just because Marvel is trying to tee up
the idea of AI to get everyone ready mentally
for Age of Ultron next year.
I don’t want to spoil Winter Soldier, but
if you’ve seen it you know who I’m talking
about.
Couslon says it himself, it’s someone who
has access to all of SHIELD’s databases
and information.
That’s why Nick Fury gave Couslon the bus
and told him to make a team to go off the
grid.
It was a way to circumvent what the clairvoyant
was doing.
Now it’s your turn though.
What was your favorite moment?
Deathlok, Sneaky May or the big Clairvoyant
reveal.
Just to be clear it’s not Victoria Hand.
She was just remote piloting the bus.
Overall I give the episode a B plus for picking
up the pace.
I think this SHIELD civil war that will play
out over the rest of the season will address
all of the complaints people have had about
the show.
I love how Skye’s character has developed.
Supposedly Chloe Bennett even revealed that
the blue alien was Kree, meaning she has Kree
blood flowing through her veins.
She retracted her statement later.
But most news sites say the way she said it
was legit.
So let’s just say Kree and stick with that.
I always love Ming Na, but May just got even
more interesting post-cougar town sexy time
with Ward.
And I love seeing pissed of Coulson.
If you remember that first Marvel One Shot
he did for Thor.
In the convenience store.
I want to see a Coulson fight scene like that.
It was called Funny Thing Happened on the
Way To Thor’s Hammer.
But let me know what your final thoughts are
on the episode and SHIELD in general right
now.
Do you think it’s gotten a lot better with
all the intrigue and action they’ve added?
Like I said, Winter Soldier review coming
this week.
Probably late Thursday Night.
In the meantime click here for the last episode
of SHIELD and click here for the Winter Soldier
trailer.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!